punch is anything that you do you need to be nice and strong and it has to be fast as well so it's
one thing to have a very strong punch or a very fast punch but it has to be both strong and fast
to get high in that in that category so the next part is your rhythm so the rhythm when you do
start your pattern there is a rhythm to the pattern it's not just really fast all the way
through it's not slow all the way through there's a slow fast slow fast kind of aspect to it as well
so you do need to kind of work on your rhythm and that's also
the last bit is your expression of energy so what is expression of energy so that's basically
uh how loud you shout so how much intensity you have during your pattern as well so i say you're
doing your pattern really well it's really fast and it's strong your rhythm is
really great but you're not shouting very loud or you can kind of tell the judges can kind of
tell oh you're not really confident you're a little bit nervous so that's what we need to
kind of improve on on as well so i'm just coming out to this side so with this one for color belts
and black belts it's actually scored a little bit differently so if you're a color belt you'll
actually uh your average so where where the judges actually mark you from it's actually from a one
point one so this is your average so say you did uh you did all right you did an average compared
to everyone else your score for one two and three it'll start from a 1.1 so if you're less than
average in the judges eyes you might go down to say for your power and speed you might get a one
or even a 0.9 if you did really great you might even get a 1.3 or a 1.4 so each individual uh
you need to obviously get as high as you can uh if you're a black belt generally depending on the
competition you will be scored from a 1.3 so 1.3 would be your average uh that you start from so
say your parent's speed uh was above average average you might get scored a one point say
let's say 1.4 for now say your rhythm was only about average uh it wasn't amazing it might be
but let's say you didn't shout very loud so your expression of energy your average was 1.3
it might drop to say let's say 1.0 so with this one we'll come over uh down to this side so
with this one uh as i was saying it's a total of uh 10. let's see for presentation we had 27
one two three so you had a
3.7 let's say you made 15 mistakes so with this one obviously don't be too discouraged if you do
get uh pretty high in your mistakes uh this is with the judges we have three judges usually at
the panel and each judge obviously it's very subjective so uh from their point of view you
might have made a lot of mistakes or you may i may have made not a lot of mistakes as well
so that's why we have the three judges and we average it out as well
okay so uh say we did our uh 15 mistakes very small mistakes so if they're all uh minus 0.1
you'd be 1.5 so you go 4.0 minus 1.5 which equals 2.5 so this would be your accuracy score
so with our presentation like before we're saying we've got a 3.7 you know so we add these numbers
at the uh
after the judges are finished scoring and you would get for this pattern a 6.2
which is actually very good so i'll just talk about a little bit more now about this number here
so if you're a color belt uh if you're a yellow or above and you do your patterns
it's not uncommon generally for a color belt uh the average is about a four
to five so if you get七, blur
a number between 4 and 5 out of 10 for your pattern that's actually generally considered
pretty good so anything above that you can consider yourself pretty good if you're a black
dog the average would say because we're talking here about the the higher presentation as an
average anything from five to two sorry five to six is actually considered pretty good and
anything over a seven is actually considered almost world class so if you get a seven for any
of your patterns you generally need to pat yourself on the back you did an amazing job so
we just went through our poomsae scoring so just remember accuracy is a 4.0 presentation is a 6.0
accuracy is judge during your pattern presentation is after and then we get two scores that we add up
get that number so with this one obviously uh say i was i was judging number one i would give you a
6.2 there was another judge on the other side maybe he saw a couple more mistakes than i did
and maybe this one would be a little bit lower it might be a five point something
another judge on the other side they scored a little bit higher so we'd get the three
numbers and then we'd average that as well so i hope this uh helped you guys so
here we're gonna say so we're gonna practice reading this will do it automatically so minor
errors major errors just press you we can't pause the video when we're watching but you can just
click this major minor it will automatically do the scoring for you then after the poomsae
you can just score yourself power coordination and expression of energy okay that's it so this
one you can just try to practice before you start i think this
is working
Thank you.